today we're here to find out whether AI
voice is truly at the level where it can
start to fool people it's uh this is
Patrick Stewart so everyone's going to
get a turn putting on a new voice and
seeing what kind of character is hiding
inside of them just waiting to come out
thanks to AI
oh no no
there are a lot of fake trucks out there
today they may look tough on the outside
but they can barely handle a few bumps
in the road a real truck can take a
beating a real truck can stand up to the
worst that mother nature can throw your
way if your truck ain't dripping wet
with mud and scum well then it ain't a
truck you piece of [ __ ]
so last time you saw me messing around
with AI voices I was breaking terms of
service left and right was this so
sketchy if I don't get your consent we
can't release this video because I might
get banned from this service and who
knows what else yes I did get banned
from using their service today we have
even more powerful software if you
thought there were ethical issues in
that last video
pull your socks up you're about to get
into the defend here okay the folks from
ultra.ai reached out to us they make a
deepaker for your voice rather than
putting somebody else's face on your
face you're putting somebody else's
voice on your voice but still your
performance that drives it unlike the
stuff we did with Jake the idea of being
able to take your voice AI mask on top
of it it's pretty crazy because right
now I can sound like a wizard rather
than sounding like just some dude in
SoCal everyone's very concerned with the
ethics of using AI to replicate
someone's likeness AI technology
generally isn't even at the point where
you can really truly fool someone
however altereds AI voice algorithm
might change that is pretty good today
we're here to find out whether AI voice
is truly at the level of work and start
to fool people so before we even get any
further here we're using altered
software right now they have packaged it
with I think like two dozen voices two
dozen voice actors which they've hired
to give them a two to three hour voice
data set so today we're working with a
library of pre-trained voices made from
hired voice actors so they have some
really good cast of voice actors here
with a bunch of different dialects and
accents so I have a great idea as a sit
down and buckle up we're gonna take our
voices and transform them into famous
characters and we'll pretend to give
everybody cameos and their favorite
celebrities and iconic movie stars you
know it's kind of Morgan freemany kinda
well can we start vlogging who's who
yeah okay we need a list of characters
so first and foremost my name is
[Music]
that's pretty good A bear with honey is
oh so funny
yeah
Jason say them let's go let's go give me
a Jason Statham reading Oh Me Oh my I
dropped my fishing chips in the loo
again
turn the fish out my fish and chips from
the loo oh here they are a little wet
Jason Statham but it's still really
funny all right who talks like that can
you go a little bit lower you can get
Michael Kane oh yeah you're just lowered
the piss and they do Michael okay can
you give me like okay in the morning oh
little Batman here come here snuggle
into my bosom let me wipe your tears
with your money you give me your wallet
here of there we go this soaps up all
the tears real nice how about cookie
his Cadence
hello Sam my name is Alan Rickman and I
play Professor Snape and your friend
Nico told me that you can't wait to go
to Hogwarts so sounds like you should
stop being into the little wizard books
sang them I think this guy for sure was
Jeremy Irons Jeremy Irons I don't even
know Jeremy Irons is long live the king
the bald guys are still my favorite
British one because he sounds so legit
all right give me give me a pen next
door give me Patrick Stewart Professor X
Professor X here's we want to take a
look at my wheelchair my name is
Professor X played by Patrick Stewart
this wheelchair of mine has all sorts of
things as a snack drawer or I put my
Snickers bar
between cuts and uh this is where I put
my gun
it's pretty good
um we need to find some more variety
here because right now it's only English
actors
here we go what does veto sound like so
he's going to be
um hey a long time ago I starred in this
movie called Batman I played a penguin
and they rebooted it
which sucks
the movie sucks are you think about
Danny DeVito I'm thinking about Danny
DeVito I don't know
[Laughter]
nothing tiny guys there's tiny Italian
men it's just Judy Dench from Mission
Earth permission impossible
Judy Dench from the movie Mission
Impossible and
um happy Monday and I'm gonna go drink
some tea and crumpets teen crumpets tea
and trumpets bye yeah
hi welcome back to the Brandy O'Daniel
segment here on Corridor crew now
courtesy of today's sponsor Squarespace
we're going to be taking calls from
people all over the place who can tell
us about the wonders of Squarespace okay
for our first caller we have John from
East London let's see what John has to
say about Squarespace yeah right so uh
Squarespace it's pretty great um first
and foremost as everybody knows they
have beautiful award-winning templates
wow that's really interesting John
thanks for calling in yeah sure uh happy
to do it all right our next caller is
Frank from the Southern United States
how's it going down there Frank well
it's pretty good and I gotta say that
one of my favorite things about
Squarespace is the members area now I
like to paint and sell shoes wow really
that I have a members area where each
month I'm able to offer a select type of
shoe to my members just through the
members area only on my Squarespace
website gee Frank that's wonderful to
hear it you sound like a smart guy okay
next up we have Miss Wendy from Southern
California let's see what she has to say
yeah I really like Squarespace because
they now have a video Studio which
allows creators to create Pro level
videos effortlessly from within their
Squarespace video Studio they even have
a Squarespace video studio app that
helps you make and share engaging videos
to tell your story grow your audience
and drive sales I mean you can do this
directly from your phone wow gee Wendy
that's really great to hear I'm so glad
that you're able to use the service that
way and wow what a phenomenal new tool
for all the small businesses out there
okay and for our last caller today we
have Vincenzo from New York City
Vincenzo how are you my friend hey Jacob
doing real good thanks for uh let me on
the air here but I'll use Squarespace
for is their top of the game analytics
you see I already have a pretty robust
website myself and one of the things
that I like to do is figure out where my
customers are coming from what they like
to buy on my site and generally how they
like to navigate through my site
Vincenzo thank you for sharing that
that's a great anecdote alright well uh
you you heard it here first you know
don't take it from me take it from all
the people who called in to tell you
about Squarespace today if you guys are
interested in getting 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain head on
over to squarespace.com Corner crew and
that's exactly what you'll get or just
hey click that link in the description
below to get 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain now let's get
back to Sam and Nico who have figured
out how to change their voices to sound
a lot like these wonderful guests all
right so now that we have our list of
sound alike voices it's time to record
some messages to hopefully brighten
Everybody's Day in the studio hey you
got a second uh yeah I think so we got a
gift for some of the people in the
office so many pranks some so many mind
games has happened in this office in the
past like month I really don't know what
to expect expect the gift okay
just to get your email okay spam oh
there it is it's high straight to spam I
don't know dude this message
seems dangerous holy [ __ ] what have you
done
uh so open that funnel yeah all right
cool
Matthew this is the one and only Jeremy
Irons your pals Simon Nico uh hit me up
on Cameo and I was delighted to hear
from them because apparently you are a
very uh handsome young man with many
talents future ahead oh I also heard
you've loved Lion King which of course I
have starred in it
um fun for news here I we are actually
making another Lion King movie I'm
excited to see you in the audience
hopefully oh anyways uh have a great day
and uh long live the king
foreign
[Music]
well we'll see now I'm I'm questioning
if this is like actually the guy
we got we got cameos you think everybody
you think you're the only one with a
gift today yeah oh there oh wow you're
spreading the cameos around aren't you
spreading the cheer the cheer Jordan
Allen we have a present for you this is
I'm so suspicious of y'all what is it so
I'm smiling look at the smile he's got
going on have you ever given someone a
gift if if it's that feeling you know it
makes you a spam folder oh right into
the spam
this message seems dangerous
you want me to do that oh Jim Cummings
do you know
wait what oh who's this I don't know who
it is hello Jordan it's your friend
Winnie the poohoo are your friends and
Nico got a cameo for me actually this is
voice actor Jim Cummings voices of some
of your favorite childhood characters
and you know I just want to say happy
birthday at least I hope it's your
birthday I lost the list they gave me so
I'm just going with what I know and uh
yeah tell your friends the Bible came
yes for me Jim Cummings all right
what yeah we got you a cameo from Jim
Cummings devil thank you so much so you
know about Winnie the Pooh he played
Winnie the Pooh and uh all the Winnie
the Pooh movies
are you like a big Winnie the Pooh thing
uh no that's why I'm surprised we're
really we're really striking out we got
you a gift
spam folder it's in your spam folder
okay not dangerous it says it's it's not
dangerous just open it oh wow
Brenna it's a big day you've made it all
the way down from Canada to the USA
this is your call Morgan Freeman and uh
your buddy Sam and Nico decided to
welcome you to their new studio with a
cameo from me
now there's a few things you're gonna
have to learn about the USA that are a
little different than what we do in
Canada
first off everyone drives trucks all
right now you're gonna watch out for
those trucks they're gonna zoom in Every
Which Way second of all you're going to
want to look into some stalls and some
Stripes once you get them you'll know
what to do with them anyways we hope you
have a real good time here working on
your visual effects I'm in some movies
myself and I might need a little VFX
help so if it's cool
[Laughter]
I guess that's where it ends
did he just start laughing is that How
It Ends he just laughs and stuff he's
like squealing that is amazing thank you
Mr Freeman would this be a good time to
have you guys open your presents sure oh
uh if you want to check in your spam
folder and Gmail is going to say it's
dangerous
[Laughter]
unfortunately it is it it is marked as
dangerous by Gmail but don't worry
yo this is Joe Pesci and uh honestly I
never thought I'd be doing cameos like
this but honestly Christian I gotta say
I heard your cooking's great you know my
mamma mia she's got a great noodle dish
too that I always been trying to make my
life never perfected it you know that's
the thing you know with family it's
always about them family dishes am I
right anyways uh so yeah you Pals Nico
Sam uh they uh hit me up told me to talk
to you about you know things you like
um are you in Vegas yeah we shot a movie
there a few times uh you've seen Casino
uh that's a real place actually you can
actually really gamble there anyway uh
the point is
um you know we're wishing you all the
best you know we're all we're all
rooting for you back here man uh you
know all your ideas put one foot in
front of the other the yeah you know
keep your chin on all right ladies
sent me a message
he's doing cameos and the dude like 100
is that that's not AI and if it is a
holy crap if that if that is an AI
generated voice that's incredible I mean
it's Joe Pesci it's crazy that's an
actor would just go his way to record
that Cameo for you check out yours oh oh
I received a present too you received a
present too
yep we got you a candy house left to
whom do I have the pleasure of speaking
the the repo of course the reaper it's
uh this is Patrick Stewart you might
know me from such famous franchise as a
stall track and X-Men are you a Pals Sam
and Nico have hit me up on Cameo which
is a website for celebrities like myself
to deliver you messages
ah of their choosing and the message
they choose for me to deliver is that
apparently uh you love space physics
uh the unknown the cosmos uh but do not
watch Star Trek and uh you know I'm
deeply saddened up at many years of my
life into that wonderful show uh well
you can catch me on season three of
Picard 2023 that's right I'm still
acting after all these years anyways
I'll have a wonderful day uh live long
impossible bye-bye yes
I am still acting
I'm
flabbergasted Sir Patrick Stewart knows
that I'm into space physics
okay this is uh basically voice deep
faking so you this isn't like the
descript thing where you had to type it
all out train to model what a defect
does is it replicates the face and
creates a mask but this is like an audio
mask it's basically the audio version of
you guys want to try it
let's go play with the voice some more
all right it's time for make your own
voices we gave away their cameos and we
totally fooled everybody so everyone's
gonna get a turn putting on a new voice
and seeing what kind of characters
hiding inside of them just waiting to
come out thanks to AI
what's montagu is it
what's Montego it is no handle food nor
are no face nor any other part belonging
to a man oh be some other name
what's in her name
that which we call a rose by any other
word would smell a sweet
wait did you turn the acting bar up
[Music]
Master Wayne ever since you are a little
boy but sought to protect you but I'll
fight you
that's it that is actually really good
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects honest react
we got a spicy episode for you today we
got some good effects we got some bad
effects we're gonna find out right now
let's get into it
spicy wow I've never heard him with such
energy that's exciting
[Music]
did you ever hear the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the Wise I thought no it's not
a story the Jedi would tell you it's a
Seth Legend Darth Plagueis was a dark
Road of the Sith so powerful and so wise
he could use the force to influence the
media florians to create life
really incredible
I know what you're thinking did he fire
six shots or only five well to tell you
the truth in this excitement I kind of
lost track myself but being this is a 44
magnum the most powerful handgun in the
world and would blow me ahead clean off
you've got to ask yourself one question
do I feel lucky
well do you punk
[Laughter]
we have a non-native English speaker
Rodrigo from Brazil I'm wondering if you
said something if we could make you
sound like a full-fledged American
right yeah
oh how big is your track brother I have
a big truck in my house I like my truck
it's big a lot of real wheel slopes and
yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what are you doing huh Hey listen you
think I download Hoagies I know Hoagies
I eat Hoagies by the barrel look we
killed Vinnie we cut his throat because
he knew too much about the hoggies what
are you doing man what are you doing
[Music]
I said Hoagies okay
[Music]
oh wiggle this weird voice that's going
on with me I had such a normal regular
voice and now I saw my Chase and sniper
in the transporter what's going on
I'm gonna stop smoking
stop smoking now oh no three haven't fun
and games with Cutting Edge technology
thanks to altered dot AI for hooking us
up with a software so we can play with
it a little bit here we have a lot of
crazy experiments we're going to try
with this if you guys have any kooky
ideas feel free to leave some comments
down below and subscribe so you don't
miss where we're gonna take this Tech
maybe this time ultra is actually
another accidents I don't know but it
can be done after the fact so we'll see
uh hopefully I sound cool later
[Music]
[Music]